foreign
[Music]
here in this video we will showcase the
11 times Cthulhu was featured and made
appearances in movies and games and talk
a little bit on his designs let's see
the entries first from a movie then a
game then a movie again and so on let's
get to it
the first one from the movie underwater
Cthulhu was reimagined and simplified as
a massive aquatic monster with no
supernatural abilities or
extraterrestrial Origins neither does
the mere side of him cause the other
characters to go insane nor was there
any Cults worshiping the monster in this
reality Cthulhu is an alpha creature in
a storyline with a massive swarm of
underwater creatures he was easily over
300 to 500 feet long but here he had no
legs but with a fin although the arms
tender gold mouth and other appendages
were all there he was also found in the
Mariana's Trench and not really
number two from the game Call of Cthulhu
in this game the storyline is more based
upon HP lovecraft's work the Call of
Cthulhu is set in a darker version of
our reality the Cthulhu appeared in the
Cinematic at the end of the game really
brought out what Lovecraft meant about
the great old one this Cthulhu a
thousand feet tall glad and darkness had
a humanoid body standing on two massive
legs and had two muscular arms he also
had gigantic Wings on his back as well
as long swerving tentacles that are a
part of his mouth this Cthulhu was also
worshiped by a cult and induced Madness
upon Witnesses
number three from the movie valdemar
Legacy 2. the film is a direct sequel to
valdemarle Legacy which was also
released in the same year the film used
many themes from lovecraft's mythology
the valama Legacy 2 The Forbidden
Shadows concludes with a sequence in
which a cult konjos of Cthulhu naturally
this deity isn't a kind God and
Slaughters a large number of people
before being dragged down into the
depths of the water Cthulhu here was
around 25 feet tall and was depicted
without any substantial deviation from
what he was described to look like
number four the shore this is a
lovecraftian horror exploration and
Adventure video game developed by Greek
Indie developer Aries dragonis the show
featured many Eldritch entities and a
host of deadly monsters including one
that was in the shape of a tall monolith
with legs the protagonists of the game
had to go through stages which ends up
in him Awakening Cthulhu from his death
like Slumber this Cthulhu had a more
bulbous head and two glowing eyes and
was around 200 feet tall
number five from South Park this one is
an animated show and it featured the
great old one in a very long sequence as
a partner of Eric godman's the
Cthulhu here is a massive
multi-dimensional monster towering over
drilling platforms so over 100 meters or
330 feet in height he possesses two arms
with razor sharp talons and on his back
he possesses two huge bad light Wings he
has a lengthy tail that he appears to
utilize to guide himself through the air
his head features two huge golden eyes
and lags a mouth and instead has a big
pair of tentacles that move as he talks
or emits vocal noises
number six Smite in this game Cthulhu is
a God that was released from his prison
made up of cosmic energy chains to fight
Zeus and other characters he is a
playable character and has a lot of
special abilities such as sending blasts
of energy summoning a portal creating a
slowing feel of Eldritch Meyer also
revealing his true form which is a
Transcendent dark ethereal form and
breaking down the mental fortitude of
enemy gods
number seven from love death and robots
here in the series which is an anthology
of different stories Cthulhu also
credited as the bounded God is the main
antagonist of the episode in vaulted
Halt and tomb he is portrayed as a
mountain sized monster chained by
Eldritch magic with bat-like wings that
are double his body length and 4 flaying
tentacles in the front of his mouth his
head is shaped in a star formation he
also possesses 12th glowing golden eyes
which he uses to communicate and
brainwash his victims driving them into
madness
number eight from the game edge of
nowhere released in 2016 edge of nowhere
is an action adventure virtual reality
video game developed for the Oculus Rift
VR headset based on lovecraft's in the
Mountain of Madness the player
encounters disturbing creatures and
monsters and climbs sheer Cliff walls as
it descends further into madness from
the great old ones effects in the
mountain range Cthulhu here seems to
have an elongated skull like a xenomorph
with long Tentacles from his mouth and a
body with an identifiable rib cage and
also 14 glowing yellowish eyes that
drives the character into madness just
by seeing him
number nine from the series Lovecraft
country Cthulhu appeared in the opening
sequences as a large multi-identical
creature with bat-like wings and
atticus's dream sequins it was barely 20
to 25 feet tall in the series appearance
and was easily killed by a baseball bat
Cthulhu here had no legs or arms nor an
upper torso but just a Bubba's head with
a tentacled mouth as well as larger
tentacles for grabbing things and
fighting
number 10 from the game king floor 2. in
this first person shooter survival video
game developed on Steam set in a
post-apocalyptic scene where deadly
clones called zets are overrunning
Europe murdering everyone on site here
Cthulhu also makes an appearance as a
giant monster that jumpscares and
attacks the players Cthulhu here is
mountainous in size and has two yellow
glowing eyes as well as all the traits
and anatomical features commonly
ascribed to him
and number 11 from the animated Rick and
Morty in here Cthulhu appears in the
opening credit scenes of each season
depicted following Rick Sanchez Morty
and summer ostensibly to protect his kid
the monster features an octopus head
with six eyes instead of two a Navy or
dark blue body a maroon coloration near
the ends of its arms it has gigantic
Wings allowed to fly and a tail akin to
that of a lizard or a dragon
so those are all the cthulhu's from
movies games and TV series as well as
animated ones so I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam